with Super Mario Odyssey finally outs
we've gathered nine cool secrets and
easter eggs that we found in the game so
far now these aren't too spoilery as
most of them take place within the first
five hours of the game but if you're
looking to play Mario Odyssey with a
pure pristine perspective feel free to
come back anyways
let's spin it if you took a break from
Odyssey to microwave some chicken
taquitos you'll probably come back to
see Mario sleeping that's right if you
leave your controller alone for a while
Mario will fall asleep and it's now
confirmed Mario dream is about pasta and
peach but mostly pasta if you wait even
longer in some kingdoms a bird will
swoop in and perch on Mario's nose and a
few kingdoms you'll come across an
adorable Shiba Inu wearing a fedora just
so I can breath the wild follow this pup
long enough and it'll lead you to some
treasure but Odyssey might take the
award for best dog does the kicker here
is that this pup will play fetch with
Cappy in the sand kingdom if you run
into a cactus totally intentionally and
not by accident the spines will get
stuck in poor Mario's nose ouch it's not
a pleasant sight of the attention to
detail here is pretty great
the pipe spewing steam on the back of
the Odyssey can be also used as an
alternate way of entering it just hop on
the back of the equip and you'll drop
down from the ceiling huh worth it one
of the costumes you can purchase at a
Kingdom's local yellow crazy cap store
is a blatant reference to Diddy Kong big
ears long tail and a red cap looks good
this awesome outfit can be unlocked by
collecting 320 moons or scanning the
Diddy Kong amiibo into uncle amiibo
Mario's poncho costume might seem like
one of the more random outfits but it
does have a direct reference to the Game
Boy port of arcade puzzler kicks in that
game's intermissions Mario can be seen
wearing a sombrero and poncho while
playing a guitar in the desert looks
pretty similar to me the mechanic outfit
you can purchase from the crazy camp
store is most definitely a reference to
Mario's appearance in famicom gram free
to 3d hot rally both him and Luigi can
be seen wearing the outfit on the game's
promo art patches on the arms are nice
touch too
if you roll on the ground in the sand or
beachside Kingdom your clothes will pick
up some of the dirt it's not one of the
craziest things you can pull off in the
game but it's a nice detail worth
pointing out in multiple kingdoms you'll
often encounter walls with 8-bit art of
both cat Mario and cat Peach these
feline versions of Mario and Peach
should be familiar to those who played
Super Mario 3d World for Wii U using
copy not cat Mario for 10 coins and cat
Peach for heart and there you have it
those were just a few of the non
spoilery Easter eggs and references but
there are tons more so stay tuned to
game spot for more Easter eggs down the
road and if you got some really obscure
ones yourself put them in the comments
below
thanks for watching
[Music]